hydro québec produit par année 200 tera
watt heure d'électricité
on va en avoir besoin de sang térawatts
un de plus ça veut dire qu'il va falloir
construire un demi hydro québec dans les
prochaines années c'est pas un petit
mandat est ce qu'on aura besoin d'autant
d'électricité en 2050
oui c'est du moins ce que prévoit hydro
québec
avec la transition énergétique la
production devrait grimper d'environ 50%
pour répondre aux besoins mais ce qu'il
faut vraiment de nouveaux barrages pour
y arriver dans son dernier plan
stratégique hydro-québec dixit à l'étude
mais c'est loin d'être une option numéro
un pour le pdj sophie brochu et si on
doit faire ça c'est parce que ce sport
nécessaire déclencher un barrage et des
environnements tollé en juin/juillet des
enjeux payton est mise en jeu de coupet
avant faire ça on peut faire mieux
collectivement selon les dernières
estimations le complexe hydroélectrique
de la romaine va coûter au total 6
milliard et demi de dollars pour
produire 8 térawattheures d'électricité
quand il sera entièrement complétée
hydro-québec veut d'abord privilégier
les projets éoliens et l'efficacité
énergétique d'ici 2029 ses 8
térawatts-heure que la société d'état
veut récupérer en économie d'énergie en
misant notamment sur le fait que
clientèle va modifier ses habitudes de
consommation certains experts pensent
qu'on peut produire 100 térawattheures
supplémentaires d'ici 2050 sans
construire de nouveaux barrages pour y
arriver il faudrait produire dix fois
plus d'énergie un lien de qu'en ce
moment ce serait énorme mais faisable
puisque le territoire du québec et
grands d'autres estiment que ce serait
très difficile d'y parvenir sans
nouveaux barrages surtout si
hydro-québec veut continuer d'exporter
de l'électricité
et à ses voisins nord-américains pour
les aider à décarbonés leurs économies